now I think you could be joined by the
other 46 million motorists in Britain of
well if that even if you're aware of it
it's very very confusing I mean the
latest thing is that as if it's not
enough to contact dvla by internet only
incidentally okay commenter on the phone
I don't know where that leads a lot of
older folk like my dad in his eighties
just wouldn't know what the internet was
you got to get that cold the only lasts
for 72 hours you need that code in order
to hire a car overseas or maybe you
don't but it's best to have the code
anyway but in addition to that you need
your national insurance number now
forgive me if I'm missing something here
but I don't see the connection between
your national insurance number and your
driving license if there is a connection
why the hell is the national insurance
number not printed on the rear of your
driving licence so it's convenient let's
have a look see the changes so this is
how the driving licence looks at the
moment is it you have your plastic card
and then you have your paper license but
from today that paper counterpart you
don't need it anymore now that's all the
drivers information was traditionally
stalled wasn't it Mike including your
penalty points had quite for your mine
at one point then you have the types of
vehicles that motorists were permitted
to drive and that was all sword on the
paper license it's now all going online
and this is what you were talking about
when you go in there they ask your
driving licence number that's easy
enough you can find that on the plastic
bit he national insurance number i
wouldn't have a clue where to find my
national insurance number i know i had
the plastic cover and I was about 16 but
I've lost that why not print it on the
back of the driving licence I mean why
didn't they think of this in advance
check out this illogical and why can't
we in the in these days of you know to
say the least a communications
revolution why can't all the information
beyond that driving license which is a
swipe card so you arrive at the the car
rental place or wherever you put your
driving licence in a machine as you will
put your credit card into a machine and
it tells them everything they need to
know about you it I mean it would be so
simple this is a lousy system this is
one of the last of these dreaded
documents for those who have never seen
one before that's kind of what all the
other lost there he goes he's clean ya
seen in more ways than one um I'm it's
an a4 sheet of paper that was a lousy
idea in the first place because why do
you need this to accompany a licen
many many years ago they should have
just designed a system whereby you swipe
the card and you know everything about
the driver the 40 million motorists
going abroad are going to have to log on
to this website before they go abroad it
crashed today so many people were caught
out thinking we're going away tomorrow
at this crash today this website but if
you're going on holiday on a Saturday
and you're not and you get your code but
you don't actually click to pick up your
hire car until the middle of the
following weeks on the Wednesday or
Thursday your code will have expired in
which case while you're on holiday you
need to get online and get back in touch
with the DVLA for a new code because the
original one would have only lasted 72
hours all right I wouldn't have believed
it unless i heard him say it myself i
heard the boss of the DVLA to today say
that he's going on holiday and he's
managed to find a rental company that
according to him doesn't require all
this information so he's not going to
bother with the code I'm not sure that's
the right message to be sent out by
anyone least of all the boss of the dvla
yeah matron groups a warning that this
going to leave holidaymakers stuck and
unable to hire a car but let's hear from
the DVLA and what they had to say one of
the things to know is that and slightly
my experiences when you go abroad
actually it's very rare you're asked for
a counterpart if you do need one just to
comfort you and make sure okay then take
your code in advance but I haven't been
asked for counterpart when going abroad
so we'll see if there is chaos and
confusion but certainly in my experience
the counterpart hasn't been used and I
says say this is a simpler and safer for
the driving public well the DVLA saying
that most people aren't even asked for
their paper part of their license when
they gave to hire a car but the AAA says
one in three drivers are asked to their
paper counterpart when hiring a car
abroad from personal experience I know
that I've come unstuck before when I
just taken the plastic bit so how joined
up is this if you go to a little rental
car company in the middle of Sicily for
example are they going to be aware of
these changes well I you know we you
won't know until you arrived what the
reception is going to be and who you're
going to get there you're going to get a
jobsworth you can it get somebody who's
new in the job who's desperate not to
take risks and therefore insisting on
the code are you going to get people
that the dvla boss is apparently found
who who are not bothered I mean he says
that most people would be okay but that
still leaves millions potentially in the
lurch we're talking about
yeah you know most adults in Britain the
vast vast majority of adults in Britain
a licence holders that means millions or
tens of millions of them could be facing
this problem when they go overseas to
rent a car and of course you know it's
not just with car rental there are other
issues as well with driving licences so
they're probably the best advice is to
go and get the code but don't rip up
that paper bitty license just yet keep
that with you too Oh Kate might write
the pleasure speaking to you thank you